[Musik]
ich bin vom dienstgrad hauptmann bin
kompaniekommandant der premier kompanie
war wirklich eine batterie und 3
überzahlspiel dabei beim
hochwassereinsatz 2013 also wenn man
dann noch in die ortschaft mit einem
pferd und wirklich die leute dann sehr
sehr glücklich sind wenn dann der lkw
konvoi von bundeswehrfahrzeugen kommt
und dann die leute ob sich zumindest
kraft mit baumaschinen mit maschinen die
dann helfen den schleim aus den
ortschaften herauszubringen
da sind die einwohner daherkommen haben
uns unterstützung haben sich aus einer
internet zu geschossen haben uns kisten
bier hergestellt natürlich ist ein
dementsprechend auch geortet worden
da ist jeder soldat glaube ich mit herz
und seele dabei
[Musik]
die feuerwehren sind alle freiwillig da
sie haben super equipment aber noch gut
ausgebildetes personal aber wir im
bundesheer wir machen das gleiche
hauptberuflich sobald die feuerwehr
quasi ausgeblutet ist oder nicht mehr
kann kommt dann das bundesheer und wir
helfen dann den leuten und sind dann
quasi auf die feuerwehr darauf gesetzt
wir bauen brücken wir helfen
katastropheneinsatz miteinander im team
in situationen wo es darum geht die
sekunde auszunutzen muss die hierarchie
greifen wenn es dann wieder sowie ein
pionier dienst dinge gibt wie einen
brückenschlag oder andere aufgabenfelder
im katastropheneinsatz das üblich ist da
wird dann das wissen jeden jedes
einzelnen mit eingebracht dieses
miteinander ist glaube dass große was
ist jetzt vermehrt gibt
das hochkar vor zwei jahren im winter
komplett zugeschneit wurde waren die
straßen komplett zu lawinen gedroht
abzugehen
da kommen dann auch unsere kräfte zum
einsatz und helfen die straßen wieder
freizumachen helfen mit den
luftstreitkräften lawinen abzuspringen
und wenn schnee wegzuschaffen weg zu
bringen
die pioniere im westen österreichs etwas
wie eine batterie und 2 wenn
katastrophen gebirge setzen und einfach
mit ihren gerätschaften mit ihren
speziell ausgebildeten leuten dort vor
ort genauso wie wir unsere kameraden im
süden unten
die villacher pioniere die haben
geschäfte rhein-hochwasser sagen heute
mit der bevölkerung sehr verwurzelt und
helfen dann doch
also wenn man sich dazu führen gemeldet
ich hatte keinen tages wieder wieder
vorherige es gibt immer neue
herausforderung wirklich sehr
abwechslungsreiche ausbildung angefangen
von spreng dienst wasser dienst brücken
bauen und das ist einfach das gefällt im
grunde das ist wirklich schön zu sagen
wenn dann alle mit herzblut dabei ist